don't want to run out of boil here
because this place is scary
i don't like when you're scared hello
we're coughing all right
i'm just going to take this back get the
[ __ ] out of here barrels all right i got
your sanity portion
which is tough now it's a tough battle
now [ __ ]
okay hey look at fun stuff
all you bros are like you can't see
anything baby you're blind
i'm not blind maybe a little
doctor said i'm fine all right what do
we got here
how this looks like a possible [ __ ] did
you put the puzzle here barrel
did you do it huh did you do it
oh
ah it was a fake present ah
i knew it i knew it i didn't know
oh jesus penis all right let's take this
with me
oh my god we need to go down here i
think
what are the battles doing what are
battles doing huh
what did you do you're trying to eat you
try to hide [ __ ] from me
[ __ ] battles hey la nada hey
uh i i was gonna say something in
another language but
i totally arrived there we go are you
happy
because i'm not i'm not no
all right i'm thinking i'm still to a
focus mr pipe
[ __ ] focus [ __ ] there's barrels
everywhere this is water
oh okay here we go let's put you here
[ __ ]
yep just fit that fit right in there
there we go perfect
okay we need the cogwheels i know this
because i am a
puzzle master in school they called oh
god damn it
hello why ah
stupid super key
barrel i hate you this is way them out
good idea peter i am the old mr chair
i have many knowledge of the share mode
and i strongly advise you not to leave
this room
[Music]
oh my god that was so close
all right we made it our life
oh we did not make it out of life but
jeremiah activated the chat remote
actually
oh it didn't work
oh i have plenty of line at him
sorry for everything oh don't smack my
face and
smack my [ __ ]
back up all right i'm out of here
hide in the closet oh yes yes
of course all right then i think of this
sooner
stay there stay
[Music]
no i'm saying here
all right still looking for
are you kidding me he's still here oh my
god
what do you want for me i don't know
what to do
he's not going away oh look oil all
right
it's a pretty good hiding spot you can't
do [ __ ] bro
you can't do [ __ ] can you go please
i don't like this all right
i think he's leaving
oh no he's not leaving he's still
looking for me
god damn it uh oh
boxes out
can you come here no he certainly gotta
be impossible
yes that's right back up [ __ ] all right
let's go over here and then maybe he
disappears i don't know
about anyone we got a key oh we got a
key
i don't even need to be here i knew that
so stupid sometimes all right whatever
let's go and uh you know push it
on i knew that i was just
testing you in case because you know
sometimes you don't know what you're
doing
and i hey why did you tell me about our
channel box
all right there's so many places here
not sure where we're gonna go here
hello oh
damn girl he's right there
okay let's go here though
hey look at 10 bucks just for me
i love to find him and books kinder bugs
are more preferred though
right what do we get hey it's you oh
you're so pretty i can't
use anything well this room is pointless
let's check the other ones
what's up these boxes everywhere and
were you here before i don't like you
definitely don't like you
oh no [ __ ] why
what did i do [ __ ] barrels
every day they [ __ ] up my lie this
current looks strong
it would be smart for me to stay out of
the water
all right let's loot some [ __ ] hey alden
lamp
hey nothing all right good what else we
got
please don't come in here
all right let's go to the sewers i might
avoid anyway
oh wait i got one sweet [ __ ] that
[ __ ] iron dude
i should oh i wonder if i can jump it oh
that'll be awesome
all right we can go here
but i have the [ __ ] sewer key what do
you want from me
there we go all right probably like a
[ __ ]
all right look at this oh no
no water monster please better not waste
my oil
god damn oh
what was that [ __ ] crashing
bottles and stuff i don't like this i
need a hammer hello
bells tell me i don't even know anymore
i saw something here
come here lightning adam come here
that's right
that's right [ __ ]
what do we got we got nothing as usual i
need that hammer girls
and boys why would they block this oh
they want me to run in the water little
sucker [ __ ]
okay that's fine i am completely
disoriented
where the [ __ ] did i come from let's
just go here
see what happened good stuff good times
[Music]
i better not go there because you know
well first of all it had barrels so you
know
that's the only clue i got oh no i don't
want to do this
okay let's just see where we have to run
all right i've gotta run there all right
let's go
oh my god that was pretty athletic of me
i'm good
hey
you're the water monster you're not
supposed to walk on land
jesus christ that scared me hey we got a
kick
all right emergency hatch all right i
know where that goes
stupid pot oh here's someone who wants
to get bath raped
this is a very awkward angle
my box is all the time stop hiding from
me
all right
[Music]
let's just go hi karamba
did it
don't follow me jesus christ i wasn't
give me my lana i need that [ __ ]
i think it's over here i hope at least
god damn those [ __ ] watermasters i
don't know if there's more than one
event
all right let's go to the creepy hatch
of hell wait i can't use it there
are you are you [ __ ] kidding me
yay i'm progressing
i mean i oh no oh oh no
ah i teleported naked guys why
are they finished here i think it
finishes there brush
no it doesn't god damn it i was hoping
for it all right
[ __ ] this i'm getting out of here now
who wants to [ __ ] them hey handsome
oh hello all right
teleporting naked guys i see oh no
jennifer jennifer why do i tell her to
mix love with
teleporting you guys you can't do it you
just can't i'm sorry pity
i love you so much i just wanted to make
you jealous
i don't care actually it's cool you can
need to
teleport the naked guys they just [ __ ]
with my life
i don't know what they want from me but
they are always naked then they jump me
i have some suspicions though all right
screw you guys i'm going home all right
oh that's not home all right let's just
go
because you know it was a good time
teleporting guys and i appreciate the
pranks but you know
life must go on as one must say
when they why is it so dark
i don't like this
oh well that's a shortcut all right
i don't trust you even though you're
just lying there
i don't trust that lamp either mr chair
what did they do ah
beauty i was horrible
i was so i'm sorry barely
i can't even talk i'm so scared i wet my
pants look oh no
i know i'm so sorry peter they took
stefano
you got to rescue them i don't even know
what to say
all right don't worry mr chair
i'll fix this i fix this
first i gotta untrust this son of a
[ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] that's wrong this line is
freaking huge
all right let's go
this looks too convenient all right
um see you later
it's your mother dear what i don't what
this is some telepathic thing i don't i
don't get it are the trees talking
my mom is not a tree i think at least
maybe eric your father has gone inside
okay now i'm really suspicious i need to
keep running
i i don't listen what your father has
done
and end this and what you're a [ __ ]
tree you can't tell me what to do
that's what my mom said oh wait i got
that
all right fine i'll just run do 360 some
shed
you're there always remember
we are all destined for good things
oh really because you know trees
probably aren't destined for that much
i love you derek that's [ __ ] gay
you're a tree i want that i'm not a tree
lover
i'm not part of green pitch
all right that was the attic
really fun custom story it was a bit
longer than i'm used to and it was very
original i enjoyed it very much
hope you guys enjoyed it as well i can
favorite if you did subscribe to grow my
bro today
and i'll see you in next video
[Music]
this is not um data's not good ah
back off back off